were they zombies walking down the
street and you're just shooting and
there's people just walking around like
what's going on right now
I remember when like a little class like
school class was like walking ha yeah
and they saw the zombies everyone oh
yeah blood and screaming and yeah it
wasn't pretty
there's so much chaos after the outbreak
it's two years before we could begin to
read into the city we started to hear a
rumor that care after he's cured of
being a zombie Allen's character allows
her brother-in-law
to move into her home despite society
turning its back on those who are no
longer infected what was your initial
reaction when you saw the script oh I
just loved it yeah everything about it
yeah I got sent and you know at first it
was prefaced so it's just you know the
zombie movie I loved the Jonah 28 days
later it's like obsessed with that movie
they're dead and you're gonna be next I
was reading it and I was just blown away
and then also I watched you know David's
short films the tree and the sort of
freak the first wave which was a prequel
in a way to this and I just couldn't
believe that I've got to be in this
person's first feature so I was very
excited where did you find this story
like how did this even develop I'm a
huge fan of zombie films and in fact it
films but it was kind of what would
happen next if there was if there was a
cure you know it's it the idea was what
what would be the film that starts and
Muslims would end how could you take
when in their merger it's a lot of them
I mean we were talking about the
underground political and and what it
means for what's happening now it's not
just a zombie movie right it's more to
it yeah there is more to it I'd like to
think that almost every script that is
like strong and whole you know parallels
a lot of you know current cultural
experience
this movie focuses on individuals who
are being discriminated out of you know
because of the consequence of fear and
fear being utilized for the gain of
power and influence on people and what
that causes and the ripple effect of it
I think that's what's interesting about
fear in this film is like you see like
it sort of branch off and really starts
to destroy everyone and I think that is
something
we are seeing right now and have always
seen yeah it's not really anything new